so welcome everyone
uh welcome to this uh pi data berlin uh
february edition 2021 uh one more time
online uh so we have two talks uh
today uh but first i would like to
remind you
uh about uh pi data so we
are uh part of num focus
and as part of focus we have a code of
conduct
uh the short version being be nice do
not
be respectful of the others
and everything will be fine
and without further notice let's go to
the
first talk by vincent
so we will talk about his work as raza
and about chatbots
and please if you have any questions do
not hesitate
to write it in the chat or if you're on
the youtube you can also put it in the
chat there
and we'll forward it uh to the speaker
cool let me just make sure i've got my
chat window open here as well so that it
looks good
uh also to the crowd like we can see me
doodle i hope right this is something
that we can all see
yes grand home grant so
hi everyone my name is vincent i won't
be talking about chatbots too much today
like i'll talk about all sorts of
byproducts that we've
got now but i won't be talking too much
about chatbots themselves
um first of all um hello my name is
vincent i'm a research advocate at braza
um so a big part of what i do is
uh i make some youtube videos explain
like some of the algorithms that we make
and the reason that i uh you know do
this
is because it's my job to sort of
interface on one end with
our research team and we're doing kind
of advanced numerical tricks to make
chatbots work so there's like
complicated stuff here
and i need to interface with developers
as well
and the main thing i'm trying to do is
make sure that some of the things that
our research team
does is you know accessible to my lovely
group of
community developers here but also the
other way around that if
cool things are happening in you know
the community that the research team is
also kind of aware of that and
this is the ground that i'm trying to
cover i do a little bit of research but
i'm also a little bit more focused
toward
developer advocacy so to say
in particular um you can kind of pick
the problem you work on it raza
but in particular i'm very interested in
doing everything uh
possible to me for non-english use cases
i think there's a lot of cool papers and
all the really cool work on english
natural language processing
but the world is much bigger right it's
not just english we
need multiple languages supported and
my particular realm of interest is this
non-english bit
so some of the things i do with raza is
i open source a couple of tools that are
useful to explore this
um i also host some browser-compatible
tools for
non-english developers but the
interesting thing that happened last
year which i didn't really anticipate
is that you know besides me being
vincent the guy who works at raza and
the person who's a
you know research advocate um i'm also
like
an open source kind of person i have
lots of hobby projects and lots of
projects that i maintain
and also lots of projects that i
contribute to um
i you know i fair learn as a project
i've spent some effort on
um there's some of these loose psychic
learn compatible packages that i
maintain
and i like to think of myself as someone
who's actively working for raza
but while i work for raza i also have my
own independent work that i'm doing on
the side
um keep your eyes peeled for a tool
that's going to come out next week by
the
way
but if i'm going to talk about anything
today what i would really like to talk
about
is how this kind of weird happy open
source accident happened
um because what happened a couple of
months ago is i was working on my own
thing
while working on the raza thing and it
turned out that these two completely
different
tracks of work we're able to merge in a
very lovely way
and the reason why i think i want to
maybe focus in on that
because it's because it also gives us a
observation
on maybe this new mindset that we might
be able to do in research which i
to me at least was kind of a neat
observation
um having said all of this
um what i'm going to do now and for the
rest of the talk
is live demoing so i'm going to try to
explain what i mean by everything i've
just said
so oh shortcuts shortcuts shortcuts
there we go um
i'm hoping this is can people read this
this is like good
size font wise cool
i think it was about five months ago i
started this open source project called
human learn and it's kind of like
psyched learn but the idea is instead of
algorithms trying to find patterns
it'd be kind of nice if we had a way to
have humans come up with decent rules
instead i think there's a lot of really
good domain knowledge and i would like
to have domain knowledge be more psyched
learn compatible
um kind of in a little bit of a project
that goes against the hype
but the main idea i really want to do is
i want to make it easier for people to
write rules
they can take in data and produce labels
because i think there's a lot of
human intelligence natural intelligence
that we can do here instead of just
always focusing on the artificial kind
and there's a bunch of features in this
library that is really really lovely
but here's my favorite one
let's say that this is a data set that
you're interested in classifying right
so
um you've got your red dots you've got
your green dots you've got your blue
dots we've got an enterprise use case we
want to
you know the classification thing that's
the thing we're interested in
then what you could do is you could say
well let's do this complicated algorithm
thing and that that's this geometric
trick that's going to separate all these
classes
but i hope that you recognize just from
you know looking at this particular data
set
you don't need any like tensorflow or
anything like that here just kind of
want to
draw a circle around the class and just
say you know if if a new point falls
within this shape
then i'll just call that red so one of
the main features that this library
allows you to do is it allows you to do
exactly this
you can just draw a shape oh i need to
use the actual mouse for this
my bad it's not great for everything
but what this library basically allows
you to do is you can just sort of draw a
shape
and say okay that's the red class
here's the blue one here's the green one
and if we ever get like a new data point
in
then we can kind of just point in poly
algorithm thing where
you know if a point falls here it's
probably green and if there's a point
over here well then it's probably an
outlier like we can do
very simple stuff like this really if
you think about it but the data's
already there
and i could do this on multiple axes
right so i
i could do this with two dimensions but
i can do this with end dimensions we're
just making more of these separate
charts and you can keep drawing
but what i thought was pretty neat just
sort of the whole design aspect of this
um what i just did is i all the data
that i just drew is inside of this
variable over here
and i'm putting that inside of this
interactive classifier which is
basically saying take what i drew over
here
and turn it into something that psychic
learn can handle that you can also grid
search over if you really wanted to
and just as a proof of concept you can
see that you know what i just drew are
also the predictions that we're making
here but
the main thing that i liked about this
view is just the whole point of
when you're exploring a data set the
first time
you don't want to do the xg boosting you
actually want to sort of actually go and
explore a data set
and by doing this trick first if only as
a benchmark
you have this nice little aspect that
you're forced to actually look at your
data and think about it
and that was kind of the point i wanted
to make with this library just a sort of
idea of you know you don't always need
complex algorithms
you can also maybe get some domain
knowledge in and have like a benchmark
model based on that so if that works
pretty well
you know then maybe you don't need
tensorflow that was sort of the vantage
point that i had
now what i'm showing you here this is
something i made on my own it's just
something i figured would be a cool
thing to do
and the nice thing about you know living
on github sometimes is that people can
collaborate
and there's some really interesting
products out there i'm not doing
anything super serious with this but i
but i have heard people like use this in
production which is pretty neat but this
is something i was doing
on my own end
while i was doing this though i started
i also started working at
raza and at raza we noticed that we kind
of had this one
sort of interesting issue and that was
that
on one end we wanted to make sure that
people who are using raza kind of
understood word embeddings
and also what's in them and on the other
side we also figured well it'd be kind
of nice if we had this really
like just useful quick api that allows
us to just evaluate a bunch of
embeddings real quick we kind of need
this library that tells us what lies in
word embeddings
and that's how the ball got rolling on
this project that's hosted on raza
it's independent of raza you can just
download it independently
but the idea of this package is called
what lies because we want to use it to
figure out what
lies in word embeddings
the way it works is you can say well
there's a back end
in this case i'm saying well let's take
some byte pair embeddings those are a
particular kind of word embedding that's
robust against spelling mistakes
and then i have this language object and
what i can do is i can
kind of like panda style just say look
if this is a dictionary of sorts of all
sorts of word embeddings
i just want to put all of my words in
there and then get sort of a data frame
out that represents like a collection of
vectors
like names with arrays so to say
so one thing that just for uh
demonstration purposes if i take that by
pair language
and i give it the word man and then i
get this embedding object
and inside of that is this this vector
so to say so this is just a retrieval
method to get like vectors out
but the cool thing about having that in
like a
data frame kind of setting instead is
that you can
more easily add plotting functionality
on top of that so one thing i can do is
i can say you could just plot the
similarity
between all the words that are in here
let's use cosine distance for that
uh oh metric
what's kind of nice and funny and
interesting and cool that you can sort
of see well there's a couple of word
clusters
happening inside of here and this gives
us like a very convenient way to maybe
explore that because
i can also tweak the settings here a bit
so i can say well i would like to have
like a larger vocabulary
size or a smaller one there's all sorts
of settings that i can tweak here
but i have this nifty little plotting
functionality that's available to me
now what's nice about this is that byte
pair embeddings are just one kind of
embedding
but there's also other types of
embeddings you can make embeddings based
off of psychic learn you can make
a tf idf vector embedding you can get
embeddings from hugging face you can get
them from tensorflow
but what lies tries to do is what lies
basically says well we make sure that
you just have to talk to like
one single api and one single api only
and we do our best to make sure that we
cover as much ground as far as support
goes
so that means that we actually have a
couple of back ends that we support out
of the box
so jensen we do uh some of this i could
learn tricks we do
fast text sentence birth hugging face
spacey tensorflow hub like these are all
natively supported so if you have any
embedding
from those then you can just use our
library to do visual stuff
basically but it's not just visual stuff
that we do
because all of our language embeddings
are also scikit-learn compatible
so i'm assuming i'm talking to a crowd
who's done psychic learn before
so if you have like your data set in
this xy format and you would like to
make a prediction
then you can use any language model that
this library provides
and it will behave like a transformer
like a standard scalar so they say
uh all of these language models that you
have here are models where text goes
in on one side of the the component
let's just draw that out
and on the other side you get basically
a vector
that belongs to that text and it doesn't
matter if using hugging face you can
always use this api
so if you just want to do some quick
benchmarks on whatever language you're
interested in
you can totally do that here
and there's one thing that's actually
particularly cool about this bi-pair
language setting because
the byte pair embeddings itself we can
kind of just maybe just show you the
website real quick
bpm it's a it's a project that
there's a couple of numeric tricks that
are happening inside of this library too
that are really awesome but
the main thing that's really epic about
this project in particular
is that it supports um
275 languages so
even if you're working in non-english
odds are that there is a pre-trained
language embedding
for you that you can go ahead and play
with um
so just to give a quick demo what i'm
just going to go ahead and do
is just type in the word embedding
languages that people were asking for in
chat so
i think romanian was one of them but
romanian is definitely supported
so what i can do is i can sort of take
this language code over here and just
put that inside of scikit-learn and sort
of play around with it
[Music]
this is the only change you need to do
to have a language embedding for
romanian
and when you run this uh the first time
it will sort of download all of these
things
but once it's done downloading you're
good to go
so just as a demo right because i think
it'd be kind of cool to show
um what i've got here is greek so just
some greek words and
i took the words that i had before to
google translate
and you can see that you know we we get
the same similarity chart out which is
definitely uh kind of nice
um and this is nice because you can also
make the comparison of hey are
the same kind of word embedding trained
on english wikipedia
uh do the embeddings represent something
differently than if i do that for
turkish or whatever other language
but i also support languages like uh
telugu indirectly however if you use
those languages you get into this
interesting other dimension of support
for language um
because i support like the the vectors
just come out that's completely fine but
the issue with some languages in
matplotlib
is that matplotlib cannot always handle
the characters
which is also the sort of small little
bummer
um so luckily one thing that we can do
nowadays on the web is we could say well
instead of relying on matplotlib it
would be nice if we can have like a
rendering engine that's kind of
guaranteed to be able to handle most
language type sets so what we also
offer are uh visualizations that are
based
on the oh whoops we need to rerun that
sorry
i thought i ran this
there we go but what we can do
is we can say well i'm interested in
making this plot but
i want to plot it directly on a web
interface
so that's what you see here because you
know a browser is actually meant to be
able to render just about anything
you'll find that there's a lot better
language support if you just have an
interactive visualization that can just
you know draw on the canvas so to say
so one of the things that we also
support is we also support this idea of
you know take the word embeddings this
is a data frame of embedding so to say
and we can say well let's transform that
by doing a principle components analysis
and let's then make these altair charts
so you can have like
you know these interactive
visualizations on the pca dimensions
let's zoom out once more so you can kind
of see it and what's kind of cool here
is you know
you can kind of explore where some of
the clusters are and if you're working
in the multi-language setting
you would really like to confirm that
certain clusters that you expect are
actually in here
before you put it into a classifier
so you know this i i figured this is
pretty useful this is pretty interesting
right like we have cycler compatibility
we have
hugging face and all these language
back-ends that's pretty cool
but here's where the happy accident
happened um
i i have these views right so i can
definitely see like hey there's a
cluster over here
but at the same time i was also looking
at this chart and sort of going
you know what's really nice about this
is that i can just draw a circle around
like a couple of points
and sort of assign a label to that using
this trick that i've got here
inside of human learn that idea is
pretty nice
and if i now start looking at what i've
got here
and you know what is actually going to
be useful to like some of my rasa end
users who i'm trying to help with known
english
well then i might need to take a step
back and wonder
maybe we shouldn't use these embeddings
just for classification maybe that's not
necessarily the big problem
you see a lot of these embeddings in the
end they're trained on something like
wikipedia
and if you think about what wikipedia
represents that's you know
amazing spelling super formal probably
about something in history
but if you think about how language is
used online like in a more
you know assistant setting it'll be like
full of spelling errors super informal
and something that's happening right now
as opposed to something that happened a
long time ago
so maybe you know these embeddings are
like pretty interesting and all but
maybe it's not just for making
classifications that they're interesting
maybe instead we should use them for
labeling
because you notice that there is this
clustering happening here right
and you can imagine that if you're
starting out with a new assistant in a
non-english setting
the probably the first problem that you
have isn't do i have embeddings
but it's do i have appropriate training
data in the first place
if you're working on an assistant and
let's say you're a business then the
likely scenario is that you do have
let's say some social media data
of like customers asking frequently
asked questions or like
you know you have these logs of
conversations that you already had
and it might be a better idea to wonder
like can we take that data
and maybe more quickly label that real
quick to get like a gold label standard
going as quickly as possible
as opposed to like only taking a few
data sets with like a
few labels and using word embeddings to
optimize uh
there so that got me thinking like hey
maybe i need to combine the human learn
idea with this what lies thing that got
going
um so
that's what i've done here
now i'm about to show you a demo but
just to give you an impression of what's
happening right
the way this this is a notebook and it's
kind of a project on its own that's open
source everyone can download it
but the way this works is i assume that
you have text that we would like to
label
i then pass that through a language
model and that can be anything it can be
something based on tensorflow hugging
face or whatever
i then end up with a embedding of sorts
and what i can then do is
a dimensionality reduction technique
that lures the clusters out
to then give me a two-dimensional view
and then probably what i can do is in
this two-dimensional view
i can do the trick where i do the
selection and maybe this is a very
convenient way for me to do like
bulk labeling i won't be getting gold
labels but i will be getting like maybe
bronze or silver ones
and the idea here isn't so much that i
get like the best labels right away
but it is the idea that i am able to
plow through lots of data relatively
quickly
so what i've got here is a
training file from a rasabot and i've
passed that through the universal
sentence encoder
and that went through umap and what you
end up with is plotted here
and what i'm able to do is just make a
selection of a particular cluster
and i can say well let's let's show the
examples of that cluster and
one of the like really convenient things
these days of jupiter labs
these widgets just kind of work so you
can just make your own user interface
happen real quick here
and you know there's actually like a
whole bunch of points here i can
actually
probably just maybe uh zoom in just a
little bit here
but there's like a lot of points over on
this end
so instead of like
assuming that these are all the rows i
can hit the show examples like a couple
of times to get an
impression of what's happening there but
at the moment i do think like hey this
is all about like restaurants and food
so let's just say this is about
like food uh i think that's a good label
for like all the points that i have
there
so that's 55 data points that's nice uh
let's maybe
uh pick up that view and move that down
here and see what
is over there okay that's all about
age all right fair enough so uh let's
add all of those labels
uh maybe do over here let's have a look
there show examples
okay that's all about jokes joke add
label
i did a couple of clusters just now and
i don't really need to see them anymore
so what i can also just do now is just
hit redraw
basically this just draws all the points
that aren't labeled yet
so i can repeat this exercise now let's
just zoom in on this uh
yeah let's do a cluster over here
all right let's just show the examples
again okay this is what
what's the time right that's also a good
cluster over there
let's maybe do this one show examples
okay that's nice to meet
okay so i got a couple of labels now
that's pretty good but now that i think
if it
if i sort of redraw now i do have a
couple of these clusters that are just a
little bit more clumped together they're
a little bit closer and i might want to
sort of
pull them apart again so what you can do
is you can say well let's not retrain
this whole language i'm betting
but what we could do is say well let's
keep using the same embeddings we had
here
but let's just retrain umap and that way
we might also still be able to pull
apart some of these clusters
to make it more easily sort of bulk
label and that's what this retrain
button does it takes a little while
but after a bit all the ui elements are
back and we see that like the chart
has reoriented a little bit the clusters
have moved etc
and you know uh i could basically repeat
the same exercise
oh draw that shape over here
show examples
about the weather what you do see is if
you move over a cluster here i mean it's
not necessarily guaranteed that things
will cluster apart this
nicely in real life i'm using a training
data set here which is giving a bit of a
bias perspective
but in reality one thing that you can
imagine is that you might need to
actually zoom in a bit here
so here like what's the time who is your
boss what company created you this
you can imagine there's a couple of
classes actually sort of hidden in here
so it's not like you can have like a
free lunch like you still probably have
to sort of go in here and
do like deep investigation but as a way
to get started
if i think about it maybe this is a
really good idea
what we're looking for are ways for
people to get to their gold standard
data set as quickly as possible
and given that i have on one end a
pretty cool user interface that can deal
with this part
and on the other end i have this library
full of embeddings that are just ready
to go
pre-trained in whatever back end you
like
i think we can cover kind of a lot of
ground here so this idea of maybe doing
more
bulk labeling as a method of getting
people's uh you know
their bootstrapped together i mean there
is merit to that idea i think
so this is
my active research area at the moment
and um
the thing with this is uh just to show
you can
nicely export this you get all of your
labels in a nice data frame
so the thing is i can try this out on a
bunch of data sets and that's pretty
cool it's pretty nice
but what i cannot do is run this in
every language out there and confirm
that this is actually working
for that i kind of need this community
around me to tell me like hey vincent
that trick works well for this language
and this trick works well for another
language
so what my job at rasa currently kind of
is i support the research team and
explaining what our algorithms are
but a big other part of my job is to
make sort of these
by-products like this and to see if this
is useful to like the larger community
out there
in order to verify that though i need
to speak at meetups and like kindly ask
everyone here
if this trick works um so if
you want to give this a go like i'll
share the links and everything
all this stuff is open source so you can
just goof around whatever you feel like
but i would love to learn this is
something that helps you get started
with a training data set
in the first place um because that's
something i would love to get feedback
on
and that is something that i cannot
benchmark on my own i actually need
community feedback for this
um
so um that's the main thing i actually
just uh wanted to say
um in general um my job really is to
make tools available
uh i literally get paid to make tools
such that natural language processing is
easier across the board
particularly for raza of course but i
have plenty of byproducts there
but i cannot benchmark data uh for you
i need to hear from you so please tell
me what does and what doesn't
work um and in particular the
another reason why i think this area of
more research is interesting
is you know in data science we very
often have this stuff that we optimize
you know that's where we could we do the
grid search where we try the bird thing
and we really
hit the power pedal to sort of uh flow
all the tensors etc
but there's also this area where
um maybe we shouldn't really optimize
too much unless we really understand
what our users care about
it's like a problem that happens in
machine learning a lot where we know
that we're optimizing something but we
aren't necessarily sure if this overlap
here is that big
so on my end um i would love to
i i would love to optimize more but
i would love it even more if people can
tell me which tools are more useful than
others and i'll gladly
contribute to projects that help you
with that regard especially if you're
doing non-english
nlp
that's it
um i there are two questions
uh as far as i can see in the chat and i
have a question as well
and the first question would be have you
considered i mean you showed only the
two-dimensional representation because
that's the only one that you can really
highlight and
draw yeah you can draw only two
dimensionally
but is there some type of tool that
you've maybe thought about
where you can just first of all switch
through all of the dimensions that you
have in your
space such that you could just basically
in each projection
you just sort of highlight it and if
it's just a different projection and
there is no cluster
to the label that you actually wanted so
there's two
two things there so first thing is um i
kind of showed up with this example
let's make that big again but in this
example like um
i have two charts here one is bill
length uh
versus build depth and the other chart
is flipper length versus body mass
so technically two charts are four
dimensions so that's already an avenue
that you can kind of do
a thing i would love to have in human
learn but it's like
good grief a whole lot of front-end
stuff i got to do there is this project
called hi plot
um it's from facebook and as these and
the idea behind this is you get these
uh parallel coordinates where you can
sort of
uh everything you see here is like its
own
um dimension and you can make a sub
selection on just one dimension at the
time
and what i would love to be able to do
is have like a word embedding where i
say well let's reduce down the 10
dimensions
and still keep most of the variance and
then say oh like hey there seems to be
like i want to get the highest value
here and i want to get the red and
okay this this might be a cluster give
that a label
and notice that when i move this around
like the the table at the bottom here
also updates
so i think as far as ui goes i think
this is something i would love to have
but i really need to do the front end
bit and that is going to take like a lot
a lot of work because
this high plot thing is pretty cool but
right now they don't support you
removing the hypot logo and they don't
it's not really an open api either so
that's
the main thing i'm battling with but
that's that's what i would love to take
this
uh labeling thing to next okay cool
so uh a question that was asked in the
uh chat but it was more of a technical
nature
when you go down to the actual
implementation of this last
uh labeling uh exactly yeah exactly
i think one of the questions was have
you used pca
is there a clustering example because i
mean i guess the question is geared
towards
um to get these nice clusters you first
have to implement some type of idea
um how this cluster will actually
manifest itself right
well so it's the thing is i would argue
it doesn't depend on
there's a couple of axes there so yes
you can use pca here as well it's just
my experience umap is just
badass it just always kind of works it's
i don't know what the secret sauce is it
just always kind of works so
i'm pretty happy with your map i
wouldn't really change that now
as far as this language thing goes here
i mean you've got birth you can use here
as well if you've got like sentences you
want to do the more contextual thing
i'm using the universal sentence encoder
here which works pretty well for english
it's pretty fast
but the thing with the language
embeddings in the end
they are trained on wikipedia-like data
sets so if
you're applying this on let's say
twitter data twitter is going to be
significantly different so then
you know these super apparent clusters
are just not going to be there
i think but then
if that's the case i mean this is more
of a matter of well it depends on the
data that you have
like if you have twitter data that's all
about people complaining
you're basically going to see like one
fat cluster in it but if you have like a
little bit of twitter data that's super
positive and some twitter data that's
super negative
yeah then you're gonna more obviously
get clusters but this is more of a data
thing
than a choice of embedding in my
experience at least
okay and another question that was just
posted by
uh somebody from austin texas
uh he asked if there's a github repo
if i mention it again yeah so there's
another github repo for this
presentation per se but like everything
i'm showing here is super open source so
if you type what lies rasa
you'll get to this github repository
it's fully
documented i'm pretty happy with the
layout
if you're interested in the bulk
labeling demo um if you type bulk label
ling raza you'll actually find like two
youtube videos that explain the
technique more in depth
and especially this video um
like it just has all the links to the
notebooks that you can just pretty much
copy and paste
um um
so like again everything i'm showing
here is open source and also all the
embeddings that i showed earlier
they're also available in raza so if
you're interested in making a raza
assistant and you're wondering hey do i
have these embeddings
i'm trying to make them available if
there's tools missing
let me know on twitter i'd love to hear
so
there's actually a question regarding
weekly supervised tools like
snorkel if there's some type of
compatibility or
if they're if you have any experience or
thoughts on
how this might work in combination with
it yeah so
um so when i made human learn i
i wasn't integrating with snorkel i was
integrating with psychic learn
and it's my understanding that snorkel
does the same thing like snorkel won't
integrate with my hobby projects that's
fine
snorkel integrates with scikit-learn
it's so far so good
i will say like i think i have a
slightly different approach though
because
um let's just go to the documentation
page for human learn
to show real quick so
inside of human learn we've also got
these function classifiers so the idea
is you can say hey here's a function
that's like a weak classifier
and you can pass it any python function
the keyword arguments become great
searchable like that's that's some of
the stuff that we have here
what this library doesn't do though
which i think snorkel does do
like snorkel has a thing of well we have
all these weak supervisors
and then we combine them in a magic way
and then the predictions better
i've never really understood what the
magic thing is that they exactly do
so that's the one thing that my library
doesn't it's it's
it's just some psychic learning
components really i believe that there
are some clever things that snorkel does
there but
um i'm really really doing like
the stupidly simple thing here that's
the what i'm trying to go for
okay i think uh there aren't any more
questions in the in the chat
so um that will be it from you
does anyone else have any questions
i have one person asking me for uh if we
have limburg
limburg's uh word embeddings um
i and the thing i think we do have them
uh
i also think we have fish to be honest i
think there's a couple of dialects in
here
lim bergen i think that's the one yep
uh it should be said though like uh
there's definitely like a lot of things
in here but i think it's also still safe
to say it's fairly european-centric this
this particular library
uh because everything that this library
does is trained on wikipedia
so if your language doesn't have like a
reasonably big wikipedia section
then there's no embeddings trained for
you so i don't want to suggest that this
is like a
you know homogeneously distributed
language embedding package
uh looking at the world but there's
definitely a lot in here which is kind
of nice
the only thing i do want to maybe
mention is that wikipedia data isn't
perfect i don't know if people
heard what happened with scottish gaelic
the story here was i believe it was like
an american 16 year old
um who basically thought oh you know
what be funny if i just upload like
wikipedia articles with words that sound
scottish and no one really checked that
and apparently
like a big chunk of the the the scottish
wikipedia
i believe was uploaded by a 16 year old
and therefore all the word embeddings
that were trained on that
uh can't be super relied upon which is
probably happening with this
uh embedding as well
but irish gaelic is also an interesting
one someone just asked
yeah so irish i guess is in here it's
also pretty cool if you go to the
documentation of this project by the way
you can
um you can basically say the vocabulary
size and how many dimensions
and then you can just get the bokeh
visualization so you can also just
zoom in and get like an impression of
all the words that are in here
on the subway so that's also something
that you can do on your own time if
you're interested in exploring this
further
so two
there's a couple of questions about how
you export the data but
it's it's indeed just the pandas data
frame uh that's it
so you can save it in whatever format
you like
if you scroll to the bottom uh here
you'll notice the uh that i end up with
this uh
data frame basically i'm interested in
maybe turning this into a package it's
just that i would prefer to have a
little bit more feedback from the
community before i do something
more formal with it
great what's the best way to communicate
with you
by issues on some type of github or
on some type of github i also have a
good lab account but i think it would be
better if people post issues on the
right repo
now so uh if you go to twitter
uh if you find the guy in the ball pit
that's me
so if you type vincent pie data you'll
probably find me but uh
fishnets88 is my alias um if you look
for raza
or like vincent raza on linkedin you'll
also find me um
if it's related to my projects i
certainly do prefer github but if you
talk to me on linkedin i will talk back
talk to me twitter i will talk back
any feedback is appreciated
thank you very much
[Music]
just see there was a last question how
can you add in the bokeh
app we via text input in new text
and enter it in the label that already
exists
it's it's all happening inside of a
jupiter notebook so no one is telling
you not to do things
uh you will might maybe need to code it
up yourself that's gonna add that
feature
but if you could do it with python code
you can do it inside of jupyter notebook
so
it should be possible
okay so yeah thank you very much
thank you interesting yeah